tenemos por ejemplo jugadores
profesionales de puertas de hopkins
sobre el villero por ejemplo si checos
rusos que vienen en canadá para para
jugar
ellos hablan muy bien el inglés después
después de después de un año hablan bien
no porque estamos así están rodeados de
sus
[Música]
estamos martín buenos días
buenas noches
buenas noches bueno aquí y aquí es la
mañana sí sí como estás muy bien gracias
muy bien gracias aquí bueno el verano
hace buen tiempo el invierno aquí el
llueve mucho
estamos bien y tú en que en qué ciudad
de alemania yo vivo en colonia
sí sí yo en colonia hace dos años y
medio sí pero soy de peru
maravilloso conoces si fuimos con mi
mujer una otra pareja y en lima en cusco
y en machu picchu
lástima que no teníamos más tiempo
porque hemos visitado a tres países en
américa latina pero lo que impresiona
bueno aún en un mes no que no tenemos
mucho tiempo pero lo que impresiona en
perú es la vitalidad la positiva de la
gente es muy positiva sin reformas no
para criticar al argentino pero haya una
una fuerza en perú que sí sí sí sí sí yo
creo que es un país muy emprendedor no
necesita no sé si porque toca que sea
así porque arriba nada funciona entonces
la gente tiene que ser muy emprendedora
pero si es un país emprendedor y eso es
muy distinto acá no sé cómo es en canadá
pero los alemanes tienen una cultura más
no tanto de emprender sino
de buscar seguridad en el empleo no de
latinoamérica es distinto eso no es
bueno si hay de todo en todos los países
te cuento te quieres que te cuente un
poco de qué va a mí mi proyecto quiere
decir es que yo te pregunte cosas
quieres pero como como quieres podemos
hablar tú puedes preguntar a mis cosas y
decirles yo puedo preguntar pero bueno
vamos a pero para empezar si tú me
puedes preguntar si bueno pregunta será
más fácil perfecto yo he estado usando
mucho link si lo uso para leer en alemán
6 lo uso para leer en portugués se usó
para leer un poco en inglés
he leído tu libro también habla de
lingüista y tengo muchas preguntas que
quiero hacerte la primera es cuántos
años tienes 74-74 tienes tengo tengo un
canal en youtube
se llama el jardín de martín porque soy
yo hablando en el jardín de mi casa he
visto tu interista con luca con lucas y
es un canal que trata sobre migración
si yo luego de un tiempo de haber
llegado acá no como estudiante sino ya
digamos como casado con una vida hecha
me di cuenta que
la experiencia de emigración no es
exacta para una persona arriba de los 25
30 40 no sé no es la misma que para
alguien que viene a estudiar no sé hay
que renunciar a muchas cosas y hay que
aprender a adaptarse y en ese proceso
creo que una clave una llave importante
es el idioma
y mi camino por aprender alemán ha
pasado por muchos lugares y ha terminado
en el canal de steve kofman
[Risas]
porque me parece muy interesante lo que
tú planteas y me gustaría saber me
gustaría que expliques para los que ven
mi canal
en qué consiste tú tu método como has
aprendido los idiomas que ahora puedes
hablar no y cómo es cómo sigues
aprendiendo
bueno el aprendizaje de idiomas es una
cuestión bueno subjetiva
puedo decir depende mucho del aprendiz
ente de la actitud voluntad que si le
gusta a la pendiente del idioma el
proceso de aprender
hay muchas cosas a mí me gusta a mí me
gusta y puesto que he aprendido algunas
algunas algunos idiomas pues tengo la
confianza de que puedo hacerlo si el que
aprender un idioma por la primera vez no
tiene esta experiencia no tiene este
conciencia pero para mí el aprendizaje
fase para él la escucha y la lectura es
que la comprensión para mí es mucho más
importante de lo que alguien puede decir
después de una semana de dos meses tres
meses este no es tan importante lo más
importante es después de un año
cuando puedes aprender comprender cuando
puedes decir sobre muchos temas no sobre
todo lo que puedes entender el nativo
cuando habla entonces la comprensión y
sobre todo bueno
no fue el caso por el francés o por el
chino y también por el chino yo no he
estudiado los idiomas en el país donde
se hablaba este idioma siempre aquí no y
yo creo que por un inmigrante es muy
importante hacer lo máximo posible para
para que su nivel en el idioma sea tan
alto posible antes de llegar al país
porque una vez llegado al país es mucho
más difícil y ahí hay aquí en canadá
había una un estudio sobre los
inmigrantes y la mayoría
después 16 años pasando por la escuela
de lino y es el inglés sting lenguas bla
bla bla el nivel que tenían al principio
era más o menos el nivel después de
siete años los que venían con un buen
nivel era más fácil integrarse en la
sociedad y después de algunos años
hablaban y hablaban aún mejor en los que
no sabían nada del idioma era más
difícil para ellos porque iban a la
escuela pero la noche con su familia
no miraban osea programas de televisión
en inglés ofrece es pero en chino o en
español
yo no entonces para mí es una cuestión
de input en lectura y escucha y cosas
que se puede hacer donde sea y depende
mucho de la voluntad de interés que
alguien puede tener por él
porque éstas se están escuchando si el
hecho de aprender pero yo tengo una
pregunta qué es
yo estoy totalmente de acuerdo contigo
100% creo que la mejor manera de
aprender es con input sí pero por qué
no funciona venir sin saber el idioma y
al país cuando en el país es donde uno
encuentra la mayor cantidad de inputs
como eres
a donde voltees hay alemana cano de yale
y peri hago esta pregunta porque estoy
de acuerdo justamente contigo yo he
encontrado mucha gente que vive muchos
años acá y no logra aprender el idioma a
pesar de estar tan rodeado de input
output input no porque bueno a ver yo te
decía alguna cosa que no es pero no
de veras es que en japón vivía rodeada
de japonés de harrods aún en japón
pasaba mi tiempo escuchando y viendo lo
que pasaba es en japón
decidí que de antes de seis meses los
los primer digamos seis meses es es lo
más importante porque decidí que voy a
vivir en japonés entonces voy a intentar
de aprender lo máximo lo más posible y
durante el bueno de primer y seis meses
año no al principio
al principio porque había mucha muchos
extranjeros en japón europeos
norteamericanos o sea que vivían en
japón en inglés
porque una vez que tienes una comérsela
estás acostumbrado a vivir en tu idioma
tienes amigos con tienes una sociedad de
gente que solamente habla o sea español
o inglés pues es más difícil salir de
esta sociedad confortable no entonces es
muy importante es por eso que digo antes
de llegar a hacer lo máximo posible y
después de llegar continuar hacer lo
máximo posible durante el periodo
inicial
para hacerse amigos para buscar trabajo
para poder entender las películas
programas de televisión crearse una vida
alemán no alemana y puedes mantener su
vida de español de inglés o lo que sea
pero hay que crear también un otro una
comunidad de idioma alemán o japonés
donde donde te sientes te sientes
confortable por eso eso eso me parece
muy pero muy muy interesante porque en
muchos hay hay muchos como gurús de
internet que hablan sobre aprender
idiomas y escuelas de idiomas que
siempre te dicen tienes que salir de tu
zona de confort tienes que salir de tu
zona de confort sé y mi experiencia
ha sido siempre que yo aprendo mejor
cuando no salgo de mi casa cuando me
quedo en mi zona de confort pero me
refiero a que cuando aprende el idioma
con cosas que me gustan no coge con
películas hablando con gente con quien
quiero hablar leyendo escuchando
podcasts
pero cuando he ido por ejemplo cuando mi
mujer que es alemana al inicio cuando
recién llegamos me llevaba a fiestas con
sus amigos alemanes yo no lo podía
aprender nada porque no entendía nada
y eso para mí no era confortable no no
era no era cómodo y yo creo que para
aprender hay que buscar lugares como tú
lo dices con confort que aún no le
gusten no sé si es porque es muy fácil y
cualquier idioma cualquier cultura tiene
aspectos que te gusta me gusta ese yo a
mí no me gusta todo en la cultura
japonesa española francesa pero hay que
buscar cosas que me brindan interesantes
no es eso y ponerte una en una situación
y tú no entiendes nada
es muy bueno inconfortable es muy
agradable finalmente no es agradable es
muy fácil crear resistencia
en contra de la cultura la gente el
idioma de todo es por eso que yo digo
que todo pasa para la comprensión si tú
entiendes porque si tú no entiendes nada
a lo mejor vas a pensar que bueno están
hablando de mí o piensen mal de mí y yo
no sé todas muchas complicaciones
frustraciones
bueno es por eso que la comprensión se
puede trabajar por su mismo escuchando o
leyendo y bueno al inicio por ejemplo
ahora para mí estoy estudiando el
presionó el árabe no tengo mi
ministerial y que voy a escuchar muchas
muchas veces mucho es el ejercicio del
cerebro pero después voy a buscar cosas
interesantes de política en el medio
oriente en cosas así no y hay que salir
de las cosas para principiantes y para
buscar cosas interesantes
pero voy a escucharle el podcast y quien
tengo una persona en tunisia que escribe
porque sólo escuchando no entiendo todo
no entiendo como 20 por ciento pero si
puedo leer y salvar frases y palabras en
link poco a poco voy a entender
a través de mi interés en la situación
política en el medio oriente escuchando
cosas empresa no bien árabe mi nivel en
el idioma es siempre mejor y ahora si yo
voy a
encontrar a 34 personas que van a hablar
árabe muy rápido no voy a entender nada
entonces para mí es un poco temprano yo
puedo entender esperar a esperar hasta
que o bien hay una o por una necesidad
una oportunidad y poco a poco voy poder
aprovechar de la ocasión pero yo no
tengo prisa
bueno un inmigrante en alemania tiene
prisa porque vive en el que es bueno sin
embargo la comprensión
todos es difícil no porque por un lado
muchos emigrantes no sólo en alemania
sino en canadá o en eeuu donde sea
tienen prisa con el idioma porque
necesitan construir una nueva vida
encontrar un trabajo sentirse parte de
un nuevo país y encontrar amigos
etcétera etcétera pero por otro lado
no no se prende tan rápido un idioma y
yo creo que también que muchas escuelas
hacen hace mucho daño esto es sólo mi
opinión yo verdad ser cuerdas en wichita
mucho daño porque te ofrecen un programa
para que aprendas un idioma en un tiempo
muy reducido muy apretado y donde todo
está enfocado en que pases un examen si
pero pasas el examen y luego no no
puedes cómo es que no no se puede hacer
tan rápido no recuerdo que alguna vez me
dieron el libro para leer más para funk
que en alemán
es una novela clásica acá
hay una película en netflix y es de
literatura alemana un nivel muy alto
y fue demasiado difícil para mí y yo
establecí como un vínculo con el idioma
de rechazo no dije no voy a leer nunca
más porque no entiendo nada
y por qué no esto no es para mí y creo
que hay muchos latinos y muchos
inmigrantes que generan un vínculo de
rechazo al idioma porque llegan sin
saber nada y todo lo tienen que hacer
rápido y no se puede no ahora después de
dos años recién puedo leer ese libro no
pero al inicio no se podía no y eso eso
es difícil no es eso lo de los tiempos
sean
te quería ser un dime dime si no claro
un inmigrante que llega en alemania
canadá a lo mejor al principio tiene que
trabajar trabajar en un sitio de trabajo
físico no porque no sabe no puede hablar
no va a trabajar en un oficio no
a trabajar algo que no requiere la
comunicación pero hoy va a trabajar a 8
horas y tiene todo el tiempo después
para escuchar el día para para mejorar
para mejorar y su universo en el idioma
entonces
cualquier inmigrante tiene el tiempo
posible para mejorarse para mejorarse
para ir y eventualmente buscar mejor
trabajo y si va a trabajar en un sitio
donde puede hablar en alemán con sus
colegas no el idioma va a continuar a
mejorarse eso es una cosa entonces si al
principio es difícil pero hay que
continuar con el trabajo por su mismo
noches las escuelas problema número uno
es enseñanza la enseñanza de gramática
si alguien no tiene mucha experiencia
con el idioma las explicaciones de
gramática no valen nada no valen nada y
yo sé que cuando yo empezaba a aprender
el alemán de hadas de ídem posible
imposible
y todos mis esfuerzos para aprender esas
carreras es inútil me gastaba mucho
tiempo y cuando yo decidí de dejar de
estudiar estas cosas y escuchar y leer
poco a poco
el cerebro se acostumbra
continuo continuar a hacer errores pero
puedo comunicar puedo entender entonces
la enseñanza de gramática que se hace en
las escuelas es muy frágil muy débil
porque se se olvide se olvide pero la de
aprendizaje el aprendizaje que pasa para
la escucha y la lectura y yo tengo como
estadísticas y en link por ejemplo de la
cantidad de horas que he escuchado del
árbol persia no es ruso cantidad de
palabras es mucho millones de palabras
y muchas horas de escucha no es una
cuestión de un case un libro los libros
los libros que se venden no con este
libro vas a alcanzar al nivel b2 20222
no no es es una cuestión de mucha
estimulación por el cerebro mucho
ingreso no importa y poco a poco hay que
dar conferencia en su cerebro el cerebro
aprende no y es y es un input que debe
ser yo lo entiendo así no como un poco
emocional como se tiene que haber una
conexión con el input no puede ser
solamente input o sea yo yo yo estoy muy
contento ahora porque estoy leyendo
bastante y leo cosas que me gustan
novelas básicamente novelas
de todo tipo pero de usar los textos
académicos de la escuela de idiomas no
recuerdo nada de eso yo no yo olvide
todo no si es que el lado emocional es
muy muy importante y que sabemos hay
todos he leído sobre el cerebro hay hay
diferentes secciones del cerebro que que
tienen que trabajar juntos para para
aprender idiomas y el lado emocional es
muy importante si te gusta la voz
de la persona que estás escuchando si te
gusta el contenido y si tú ya sabes algo
si es un contenido familiar no como algo
que tú sabes vas a disolver más y si
entiendes más y si te gusta aprendes más
entonces sí y por eso en las escuelas
porque los profesores a los enseñantes
quieren enseñar quieren controlar
luego yo te digo tú tienes que leer esto
tú tienes que hacer esto tú tienes que
aprender esto y si el enseñante piensa
si yo enseña por ejemplo el conjuntivo
en español después voy a estar para ver
si tú has entendido o bien tú vas a leer
una cosa y van a preguntar de darte esas
preguntas de comprensión yo oí
mi comprensión es eso es incorrecto
yo no es esto no es importante es el
hecho de que el idioma entra en la
cabeza
ence en la cabeza yo entiendo como el
50% o 60% el mal comprendido este no es
importante entonces lo más importante yo
creo que las escuelas hacen daño como
decís porque porque el enseñante quiere
controlar
aprendiendo es el aprendiz ente que
tiene que controlar su propio estudio
del idioma aprendiz aprendiz aprendizaje
en presentarse ahora que tenía dos
entrevistas en italiano ahora esto está
mezclando todo aunque no hay problemas
tengo otra pregunta que tiene que ver
con eso he visto algunos o varios de tus
vídeos donde explicas explicas tus
procesos de aprendizaje de los distintos
idiomas que has recorrido
y sé que algunos los hablas muy bien y
otros más o menos y otros los has
olvidado
no sé sin embargo todos
los entiendes a cierto nivel no sí y eso
para mí es muy interesante porque es
como lo contrario a lo que te ofrecen en
otros lugares hay hay mucha gente que
está ofreciendo como habla en tres meses
habla tienen programas para hablar para
hablar
en tu caso entiendo que tu interés no es
tanto hablar sino es entender es así o
no
mi objetivo
final bueno es poder hablar y hablar
bien yo quiero hablar bien pero también
me gusta
yo estoy aquí en años
me gusta me gusta descubrir nuevos
idiomas nuevas culturas
y claro que hay idiomas que he aprendido
checo el griego el que hablo mal pero
con un poco de trabajo para refrescar
puedo hablar más o menos otra vez pero
ahora sería difícil pero el quiero
hablar
quiero hablar pero yo vivo aquí me cubre
no puedo buscar cada día árabes griegos
y españoles no entonces lo que yo puedo
hacer es escuchar por acá sobre la
política a la cultura entonces por el
momento estoy aquí aprendiendo de una
manera buena manera pasiva pero por
ejemplo el checo estudiado durante un
año y durante ocho meses meses y después
me fui en la isla de creta me fui en en
praga me fui allí para para poder hablar
no a mí me gusta hablar me gusta hablar
con la gente pero hay que ser hay que
estar realística
y es que bueno con el tiempo que tengo
con todos los idiomas que quiero hablar
que quiero descubrir que son muchos
bueno entonces sí pero los los idiomas
que hablo mejor son los idiomas que he
hablado más para hablar bien tienes que
hablar mucho
sí ese es un punto importante no para
hablar hay que hablar y para aprender
hay que escuchar y leer no es éste sino
hay hay un tema con esto que estamos
hablando que es el aprendizaje o el
idioma pasivo y activo no de yo recuerdo
que una vez postulé a un trabajo cuando
cuando llevaba un año apenas en alemania
para
el video acá está el vídeo editor de
vídeos
y estaba yo y había un chico de portugal
y el chico de portugal tenía 7 años
viviendo en alemania y yo tenía uno y yo
hablaba mucho mejor en un año que él
pero el trabajo lo obtuvo él y después
me di cuenta que era porque él entendía
mucho más que yo podía como entender más
y para ese puesto de trabajo para editor
de vídeos uno no necesita hablar tanto
sino necesita entender lo que está
escuchando para poder trabajar no
entonces mi pregunta es
en qué momento
se tiene que pasar porque evidentemente
este chico de portugal tenía un nivel
del idioma pasivo mucho más arriba que
yo se entendía mucho más que yo y yo
entendía menos pero hablaba más mi nivel
activo era mayor no
como sé cómo se hace para todas esas
palabras que no almacenen link todas
esas palabras que uno escucha todas esas
palabras que uno lee todos esos
estructuras que uno absorbe llevarlas al
activo porque él tenía el problema de
pasar todo activo no bueno
para mí para hablar bien tienes que
hablar mucho pero es así para para
hablar bien también para hablar mucho
para hablar y no solamente hablar de
cómo estás
hace buen tiempo no para hablar sobre
temas distintas sobre política sobre yo
no sé la cocina muchas
en temas diferentes no es necesario
tener un buen nivel de comprensión
entonces para mí hablar bien con bueno
entonces necesitamos un vocabulario
pasivo grande porque el nativo tiene
hopper tendría tendrá siempre un nivel
de vocabulario pasivo más grande que nos
como que nosotros como extranjeros
porque con toda su vida viviendo con el
idioma tiene gran vocabulario y nosotros
podemos aprender muchas palabras pero
siempre menos que entonces tenemos que
defendernos
porque la comida la variedad de palabras
que puede utilizar el nativo o en
películas o en un vídeo todo lo que sea
es muy grande tenemos es que para
defendernos necesitamos muchas palabras
palabras pasivas y voy
vamos a utilizar mucho menos palabras
palabras activas palabras que nos gusta
nos gustamos utilizar son
palabras favoritas no de frases
favoritas para construir nuestra
discusión pero hay que entender y si tú
no entiendes lo que dice el nativo es
muy difícil mantener una discusión pero
si tú tienes algunas dificultades para
expresarte en este no es tan importante
se va hablando va mejorando se pero hay
que entender entonces para mí todo paso
para la comprensión pero si uno como el
chico portugués no tiene amigos alemán
no va a encontrar gente con quien hablar
en alemán y claro que va a hablar bueno
menos bien pero pero para mí la
prioridad a la comprensión una vez que
tiene bueno si estás viviendo en
alemania a cada nivel de comprensión que
tienes puede hablar con con con gente
pero hay que continuar este trabajo de
import para
que el nivel para la cantidad de
palabras del bus caminar crece
que puedes entender más y más y después
continuar también hablando no es una
contradicción pero hay tipos si conozco
a gente que leen bien que no quieren
hablar bueno es
es una cuestión de personalidad de lo
que alguien quiere hacer si el portugués
es casado con una portuguesa vive en
familia no tiene amigos alemán digamos
bueno que va a hablar buenos días
yo me da cuenta que por ejemplo aquí
quizás lo mismo en alemania tenemos por
ejemplo jugadores profesionales de
fuertes no de hopkins sobre el villero
por ejemplo si checos rusos que vienen
en canadá para para jugar
ellos hablan muy bien el inglés después
después de después de un año hablan bien
porque estamos así están rodeados de sus
con compañeros compañeros si quieren
quieren estar juntos con ellos quieren
son juntos
juntos pero quería pero a profesores
rusos o alemanes que enseñan a la
universidad y que tienen una meta muy
fuerte que viven en otro mundo por eso
es una cuestión de para hablar hay que
crearse una bueno una comunidad de
amigos y con eso para hablar si eso es
muy esto que acabas de decir para me
parece muy interesante porque yo he
entrevistado este todo este tiempo a
muchas personas que con distintas
historias de inmigración y me doy cuenta
siempre que las personas que mejor
hablan son las personas que han
estudiado acá y no por estudiar sino
porque han
han hecho amigos alan jhones no sé y yo
creo que lo que sucede en la universidad
o en la escuela es que esta gente
usualmente jóvenes tienen como una
necesidad de pertenencia como un sentido
de querer pertenecer a un grupo como ser
aceptados o ser integrados o ser en
cambio el que viene con 40 años casado
ya como dos hijos una familia hecha no
tiene la necesidad de que alguien lo
acepte porque sus amigos no están acá
están en el eje yo y pasa eso no sí
aquí por ejemplo los inmigrantes que
vienen en canadá pasando en cierto edad
no es que no quieren ser aceptados
porque es muy fácil cuando tú tienes
bueno 20 años no tú no va a juzgar de la
sociedad local de sus culturas de sus
costumbres
aquí soy yo yo no soy no yo no vengo con
la bandera de canadá ni de perú yo vengo
aquí tú eres alemán y vamos a hacerse
amigos
y todos los que vienen con de 30 o 40
años siempre el inmigrante siempre
piensa que la cultura del país de origen
era mejor por tal razón si en el alemán
ya tienes algunas calidades de buenas
pero finalmente no es no son buenas
personas como nosotros canadienses
peruanos botes de entonces este es un
factor tienes que aceptar gente del país
donde vives ahora que es una persona tú
no tú no tú no estás representa
representan ese representando a tu país
con la bandera no es en tu identidad
es una persona punto y el otro también y
hay que buscar amigos no tienes que
qué te gusta todo en la cultura alemana
pero hay que buscar amigos
hay que buscar ciertas cosas y que esas
cosas te dirige ver verso que tenías
ganas de aparte de pertenecer y
desgraciadamente muy muy de menudo la
gente de más edad no no quieren no
quieren quieren
mantenerse al lado no por qué crees que
pasa eso es porque lo veo mucho acá no
sí bueno es hay muchas razones puede ser
una reacción defensiva
que tú no me acepta entonces yo no te
quiero
ok es algo así o bien pero es también
eso hay que hay que tener
hay que tomar una oportunidad duro está
mano un riesgo de venirse reig acción no
hay que ser porque finalmente la mayoría
de la gente que sea canadá perú alemania
te aceptan como individuo
o te gusta o no ok pero a este nivel
individuo con individuo hay que crear
relaciones en seguro que por cada
inmigrante hay personas en alemán
alemanes que pueden ser amigos
y yo creo que también tiene que ver un
poco
un poco con la manera que tenemos de ver
las cosas cada cultura y por ejemplo el
latinoamericano en general
son los países son distintos pero los
latinos en general
son personas que están muy abiertas a un
primer paso vengo al bolton a hablar muy
rápido los italianos también son así
y luego deciden si quieren continuar una
relación con esa persona y los alemanes
creo que no son así creo que ellos
piensan antes de dar un primer primer
paso no se piensan primero si realmente
quién pasa no les interesa mucho hacer
small tok porque su cultura es es otra
es otra manera ellos tienen otras
maneras de hacer amigos no y eso produce
un choque no
es posible es posible pero también tú
como inmigrante estás viviendo en el
país de los alemanes que tienen tres
amigos que tienen sus padres que tiene
toda una una estructura de obligaciones
llena de amistad de relaciones de todo
esto entonces tú el extranjero no
no es cada bici de los alemanes y yo
creo que la misma cosa puede en perú
no es el peruano que quiere buscar
nuevos amigos extranjeros porque tiene
llega a una cantidad de conexiones es
posible de ser eso sí sí no no no no no
es una crítica no me estoy creando no es
solamente digo que a veces las culturas
son distintas y es difícil para una
culpar a alguien que viene de una
cultura a aceptar que tiene que estar
entrando a conocer una cultura nueva que
existe en tu caso tú tú vas como
recorrido y aprendido distintas lenguas
y hay algunas de las lenguas
algunos de los idiomas que ha explorado
que que a lo que a cualquiera se le
haría difícil de poder imaginarse como
el árabe como el chino
esos son idiomas que parecerían que
están muy cerrados
qué es lo que a ti te interesa de poder
conocer
aprender esos idiomas bueno en el caso
del chino yo trabajaba por el gobierno
canadiense y
en esta época el gobierno canadiense iba
a reconocer la república popular de
china entonces necesitaba
a ver son personas que hablan chino
ellos me han pagado el estudio del chino
y después fui transferido al japón y
vivía nueve años cuatro años en la
embajada y cinco años trabajando por dos
empresas canadienses de exportación de
madera en el japón
bueno el árabe el persia no es porque me
quiero saber bueno el ruso al aire 60
decidir aprender ruso y después de ruso
es un idioma no es suave entonces bueno
ucraniano checo y tengo como idiomas
romances no francesa italiano romano
digamos germánicos do yo no sé como dice
en español germánicos germánico no es
sueco alemán y asiáticos como japón es
un poco de coreano and chickens quienes
han decidido aprender algo sobre el
medio oriente bueno y medio oriente es
árabe cristiano y turco y después voy a
continuar en la dirección al oriente
entonces el urdu que es el idioma de
pakistán y después del hindi
bueno a mí me gusta descubrir descubrir
idiomas pero quiero decir que por
ejemplo viviendo viviendo en japón
en china se siente que hay muchas
personas no te gustan
a ellos no les gustan el hecho de estar
con un extranjero
ay bueno no todos quizás no la mayoría
pero sí muchas veces siento esto que mi
presencia para ellos es inconfortable
ellos prefieran solo chinos o japoneses
pero la misma cosa existe en canadá
también puede decir en alemania
y puede ser según la persona
tú eres interesante porque es extranjero
y eso está bien y otros neutrales y
alguien es que a mí no me gusta bueno
hay que vivir esto hay que vivir eso yo
yo no tengo
bueno hay que pensar a todas las
situaciones positivas y no tan
concentrarse en las cosas menos
positivas que hay que hacer una
selección porque no todas las
situaciones van a ser positivas en
alemania en perú
si definitivamente no
y una pregunta más que te pregunte al
inicio de la gente porque tú sigues
aprendiendo idiomas cualquiera quizás se
podría preguntar si tienes 74 por qué ya
no simplemente vas a la playa o de
vacaciones y dejas de aprender porque
sigues aprendiendo idiomas hasta cuándo
lo vas a hacer por qué por qué lo haces
bueno a mí no me gusta la playa bueno me
gusta me gusta nadar no aquí muy cerca
hay los típicos way nadando cada día
ahora en el verano pero bueno es una
actividad que me gusta me gusta viajar
pero ahora con el joven no se puede
viajar pero sí por eso que con mi esposa
hemos visitado bueno argentina brasil
perú y
marruecos y está bien mal no me gusta
viajar me gusta jugar al golf con él y
me gusta encontrarme ahora menos con
amigos pero con la familia
no me gusta hacer muchas cosas pero en
la posibilidad de sentarse aquí y a
través del internet descubrir muchas
cosas sobre la historia del medio
oriente medio oriente por ejemplo ahora
no que estoy y no solo voy a estudiar él
presionó el árabe pero con eso me
interesa en mi interés en esta región
está creciendo he comprado otros libros
sobre la historia de esta región es es
una posibilidad de descubrir cosas sobre
el mundo en que vivo no es interesante a
otras personas que quieren mirar
películas o beber
todos tipos de intereses para mí es algo
que me interesa
no te preguntado esto pero cómo funciona
cómo aprende es tu idioma yo lo sé
porque sigo tu canal porque conozco tu
contenido pero ahí hay gente que va a
ver este vídeo que no te conoce cómo es
que tú aprendes tus idiomas son los
idiomas que has aprendido
bueno
bueno siempre escuche voy a empezar con
la escucha y la lectura que quieras que
voy a comprar un pequeño libro de
introducción al idioma con unas
explicaciones de cómo funciona el idioma
ahora este es menos importante que antes
porque puedo buscar una explicación del
de rome no del griego en el internet
puede descargar google descargar pdf
sobre la gramática
pero sobre todo es que quiero escuchar
lean mucho y ahora en el link utilizo
mucho los ministerios que me han ayudado
mucho para poder hablar más temprano
porque antes esperaba seis meses antes
de hablar y antes de empezar a hablar
me necesitaba como diez mil palabras en
checo por ejemplo para poder empezar a
hablar ahora con los ministerios que
tienen muchos mucha repetición verbos de
alta de frecuencia muy alta no puedo
empezar a hablar más rápido pero después
de los ministerios si es en una
escritura latina como el rumano bueno
puedo pasar enseguida en cosas más
interesantes con el griego más difícil
aunque sea un alfabeto pero es un poco
más difícil pero con el árabe el
teresiano necesita mucho más tiempo y
desgraciadamente hay
poco contenidos de un nivel intermedio
entonces ahora con el árbol versión no
estoy escuchando podcast de política
porque me interesa
política historia escuchar el podcast
que no entiendo muy bien y hay una
persona que me ayuda a hacer la
transcripción y después leyendo y
trabajando en link y poco a poco pero
muy poco a poco es es un proceso sin fin
un proceso lento la gente que aprenden
idiomas tienen que darse cuenta que
durante mucho tiempo las cosas será y
serán muy no muy claro no no no bueno
vamos a comprender y buscando las
palabras y todavía no entiendes
por qué
este continua continua pero para mí el
objetivo final vale la pena y yo soy de
mi experiencia y este también es de una
diferencia con gente que no tiene esta
experiencia dios
georges show show 6 buen game show kim
feast sé que al final
podré hablar en este idioma aunque ahora
sea muy tengo mucha frustración de no
poder entender de no poder hablar de
olvidar pero finalmente voy a poder
si no es no es tanto y rápido sino ser
constante no más
y de algo que has dicho que me parece
muy interesante es el tema de encontrar
contenido intermedio eso yo creo que es
muy muy importante no hay he visto
muchos casos y a mí también me ha pasado
que empecé con contenido básico
y es muy fácil quedarte solamente en lo
básico en lo básico en lo básico y
cuando quieres dar un paso más adelante
un error típico es que de frente agarras
cosas que son muy difíciles
y no y no y no pasas por lo intermedio
no sé yo si ese es un problema hay que
buscar cosas para para mí
cosas que me interesan por ejemplo la
historia
si tienes un contenido que es
interesante para ti y el en inglés
non fiction como existe
y literatura es mucho más difícil hay
que darse cuenta que literatura es más
difícil aunque no ficción o también
diálogos de películas porque hay allí el
vocabulario utilizado es mucho más
limitado entonces hay que tener una
estrategia estrategia de escoger cosas
más fáciles
netflix por ejemplo con el link puedes
buscar películas en youtube netflix
importar el diálogo como lección en link
para estudiar y yo he hecho la si yo voy
a buscar un artículo de un periódico
para estudiar en link por ejemplo hace
bueno algunas meses en árabe ayer como
40 por ciento de palabras que yo no
conocía aunque yo
había encontrado en el link pero con
diálogos de netflix era como 15 por
ciento de palabras no conocidos
conocidas entonces de hay que decir que
las cuales las películas tiene un
diálogo porque él
lenguaje de todos los días es más fácil
que un artículo de la misma manera en
polaco por ejemplo después de cosas muy
sencillas he podido
escuchar un libro audio libro sobre la
historia de polonia y leer este mismo
libro y voy a buscar entonces donde hay
el audiolibro el libro en forma
electrónica que haces al mismo tiempo
pero muchas no lo porque para mí la
escucha es una cosa yo no puedo sentarme
y escuchar yo voy a escuchar trabajando
lavando los platos los platos son en el
coche porque si yo voy a sentarme es
para escuchar
ya voy a pensar otras cosas pero si ya
estoy haciendo muchas otras cosas
yo puedo explicar bueno entonces la
escucha es una cosa que hago muchas
veces durante el día
de 5 minutos una hora pero después voy a
leer para saber de qué trataba porque me
lo haces si lo haces todos los días no
casi todos los días porque yo preparo
de desayuno y café de mañana si yo lo
hago entonces 15 minutos después yo voy
a limpiar 15 minutos yo ahora soy el
marido modelo porque escucho siempre los
idiomas si en el coche yo voy a hacer
ejercicios voy a escuchar
hay que hay que tener está esta
motivación
antes antes de que se nos acaba el
tiempo solo para tener una idea general
cuantas cuantas palabras se necesitan
más o menos para poder
en tener una conversación la gente no
sabe si según la conversación pero si tú
estás sentado en un bar y quieres hablar
con una alemana bueno la conversación
puede tratar en muchas cosas de política
desde fuertes desde mucho no entonces
para poder tener conversaciones sobre
temas distintas
y bueno en link la manera que
como dice que cuentan las palabras es
que cada forma de la palabra ya es una
palabra distinta si no hay palabras
donde hay muchas formas de cada palabra
y hay otro idioma es menos pero
normalmente yo creo por el alemán 20 mil
20.000 según la manera que contamos
contamos las palabras en 20.000 no es
menos
no hablo muy bien
hay muchas formas de las palabras el uso
yo tengo 24 ahorita bueno en alemán en
alemán sí pero pero creo que dice allí
sino en la misma compra ten pero tengo
creo que tengo 24 en link pero en mi
cabeza tengo más porque recién estoy
acumulando lo que es y 24.000 difícil
24.000 sailing pero yo creo que en
realidad tengo más más porque estás
leyendo otras cosas yo yo cuando estudio
el árabe sólo en link pero tú estás
leyendo libros estás leyendo periódicos
sí sí sí estoy hablando con la puede ser
el doble puede ser el doble
si yo yo creo que tengo pasar mi
estimación es que
40 no hablo perfecto no pero sí sí sí
pasa puedo hacer todo en alemán no tengo
ningún problema en el aire sí
y para tener un nivel avanzado
serán que treinta mil palabras 40 mil
según por qué
lo que pasa es que la frecuencia de las
palabras de niño es muy rápidamente
entonces mil palabras
hay una frecuencia muy alta y puede
después la frecuencia divino y muy
rápidamente entonces si hay palabras que
van a aparecer en un libro una vez
en todo el libro una vez dos veces
entonces vas a continuar a descubrir
nuevas palabras siempre y siempre
tendría palabras que ya no te vas a
olvidar y también palabras que no
conoces que hacen o que nunca has visto
o bien que has visto pero haya olvidado
exacto si nacía de la vida así es la
vida buenísimo muchas gracias steve por
la conversación
voy a dejar en mí en mi canal voy a
dejar tus el link a tu a tu canal en la
descripción pero si puedes recordar cómo
se llama bueno yo soy el link o steve en
youtube el link de por supuesto es el
el plataforma de rim de saque de idiomas
y bueno buenísimo bueno listo muchas
gracias a que gracias a ella
[Música]
y